thank you
it's breathtaking
[Music]
when you see sand here imagine water if
you dive in you can't reach the bottom
you dive in yes it's cold swimming I
don't I don't believe you
[Music]
in the shadows of Iraqis
Romaine
the end of House of treaties your father
didn't believe in Revenge
what if Paula treaties were still alive
who came out
have you ever had a dream about your
first ride
don't try to impress anyone
you're brave we all know that
be simple
be direct
nothing fancy I understand
nothing fancy
[Music]
you will never lose people in trainings
we gave them something to hope for
that's not hope
May thy knife chip and shatter
[Applause]
[Music]